survivors earth vessel few bags left
after 66 days stranded at sea this
sailor finally has his prayers answered
Coast Guard's carefully winch Louis
Jordan who SAT inside a rescue basket
into the safety of the helicopter he was
found by a German containership of the
coast of North Carolina sitting on the
whole of his capsized boat the 37-year
old had set off on a fishing trip on the
twenty-ninth of January but poor weather
conditions snap the ship's mast and
broke all lines of communication with
the outside world sure of course our
thanks for your help today we're headed
back to short I was actually sleeping
and that's when it happened but before
that happened there was very bad weather
and the waves were huge and the wind was
strong but I didn't know that because
I'm an inexperienced sailor I haven't
had a lot of time on the water and I was
just praying to God you know please
protect me for the first time since
January he takes his first tentative
steps onto land the beard the only
outside evidence of his ordeal his
family who spoke with him on the phone
state his religious belief and strong
constitution is what kept him alive I
heard you so long oh man nice to hear
your voice we've been praying for you
how are you feeling I'm doing right now
you know I couldn't I couldn't fix it I
couldn't sail back with my boat I'm so
sorry such a big loss hey Lois you're
fine I'm so glad that you're alive Lewis
is suffering a broken shoulder and
dehydration but managed to sustain
himself by catching fish with his hands
and clothing and by drinking rainwater I
wasn't going to live off of seaweed
because I had only eaten a tiny bit and
there is Seeley floating out there but I
did collect a bunch of seaweed I found
that there were these little crabs his
little critters living in the seaweed
and it tasted dang good
his parents are now on their way to the
hospital to be reunited with their son
in person more than two months after
they reported him missing Joanna Simpson
Sky News